I had my interview with Michael Gove
there now a medium-sized economy in a
period of decline with poor productivity
or one of the world's richest countries
with Innovative in Industries waiting to
be Unleashed well the chancellor tells
us it's the latter and wants an end to
what he describes as decline isn't about
the UK economy that he says is holding
us back but what is the view of business
and how is the government managing it
well we can try and find out Siobhan
Haviland is director general of the
British Chambers of Commerce she joins
us now thank you so much for being uh
with us um
towards the end of the uh I'm just
kicking the desk towards the interview
uh their end of the interview there with
the leveling up secretary I was trying
to say you know is the government doing
enough is it being uh thoughtful enough
or is it just trying to kind of steady
the ship and he said no no it's all
about big ideas and he pointed to the
chancellor speech this week what's your
take is the government taking enough
risks
so I was at the chance of speech on
Friday
um and it was uh good to hear him being
really positive about British business
uh in this role with the chambers I have
the joy of traveling the country and
meeting businesses all over our regions
and Nations and you know we are we do
have amazing Innovative growing
businesses so we do need to be really
positive about that
um and it was a step in the right
direction but it is a framework uh we're
probably missing a couple of E's from
his framework on export and energy
um but what business really want to see
is action and changes and policies it
felt like there was a lot of words and
not that much in terms of policy do you
think that's fair yeah I think that's
fair I mean he did say that's what he
was laying out was a step in the right
direction for a something that looks
like a strategy but what we really want
to see is on areas like export you know
that's a huge growth area for us as a as
a country we need to fix the Northern
Ireland protocol so we can trade more
easily with our biggest trading partners
we need to see support for businesses on
their energy bills of course the support
for businesses on energy was uh was
fantastic it's been over the last six
months but it's coming to an end in
March we've got a new uh package it's
much much lower than the last and when I
travel around the country and energy is
really energy bills are really a concern
for business and of course people
getting the right people to run their
business and you're talking there about
exports and also about getting the
protocol right the Northern Ireland
protocol the famous uh protocol
do you think that the government is I
guess reluctant to talk honestly about
the impacts of brexit for political
reasons
so
um export businesses that export are
more resilient they're stronger they
last longer they pay better it's it's
incredibly important and those who had
been exporting to the EU have had huge
issues over the last two years I mean I
mean food and drink businesses who have
just stopped exporting to the EU because
it's too difficult and that is the
opposite of growth so getting the
Northern Ireland protocol away is going
to be really important to then going on
to fixing the bits of the trade
agreement that aren't working around
that around food and drink exports I
mean they really everywhere I go they
tell us it's a significant problem and
that's not just export of goods that's
use of Professional Services moving
people around Europe or all of that are
you optimistic that the government could
actually do something about it
we're hearing positive things about
Northern Ireland protocol I was with the
EU ambassadors earlier this week they're
also feeling positive so that's going to
be a big a big thing if we can get past
that that's interesting is there any
sort of time scale that they're giving
on it
we're hoping for this quarter we really
need to see it this quarter because that
that way we can move on with the special
committees and we can fix the bits that
aren't working that's really interesting
uh just staying on the chancellor speech
he talked he railed against declinism he
was saying there's too much pessism
pessimism about the prospects of the UK
economy but you know
in a way I kind of think we're the only
G7 economy still smaller than before the
pandemic inflation is higher here in
comparison to other countries we've
talked about the trade hit that many
businesses have seen we're getting
poorer that's not decliners and that's
reality right
when I when I meet businesses of the UK
they do lay out the challenges that
we're that we're facing and some of the
fixes that we need on that but business
people are by their nature optimistic
they're forward-looking they're positive
and Friday after I saw the chance that I
went to Huntington I'm an amazing
business that is in Advanced Materials
unique Global IP founded here growing
here and that's what we want to talk up
that's what we want to see more of but
there are some issues that we need to
fix so everywhere I go businesses say I
can't get the people I need to grow my
business so we want to see a bit more on
that sort of skills development piece
there are some good things going on and
on on that because there's been quite a
focus on the over 50s is that the rights
policy or are they perhaps people who
don't necessarily have the skills for
the jobs that need fill in it's part of
the answer it's part of the answer and
we're working with government on the
economically unactive the chance to talk
about it on Friday uh that might be
people over 50 coming back into the
workforce but actually we need to look
at Childcare so we can bring carers and
parents back into the workforce and
honestly we have 1.2 million open roles
in this country by the government's
estimate that's about 500 000 people and
when I go around the country businesses
always also tell us we need people from
uh the rest of Europe to come in and
work in this country so we really want
government to look at their shortage
occupation lists the structures that
allow them to bring in short-term visas
for people in areas like Hospitality
where they're really struggling we'll
talk about childcare a bit later it does
feel as if it's a really important topic
to talk about if you're talking about
getting people back into the workplace
right and there's also a big debate in
the conservative party about that
now the line from the chancellor is that
the best tax cut is getting inflation
down but do you think there is a role
for tax cuts so it's good for individual
for consumers because they feel there's
a bit more money in their pockets
obviously that's good for business and
businesses want to see uh taxes kept low
at the front end so that they have
enough cash to invest in their
businesses but actually what they really
want to see is better access to people
so they can grow their businesses
helping them with their with their
energy bills but also you know we have
huge opportunities in green Innovation
for example so how are we supporting the
green accelerators we've got across the
country how we're investing in
infrastructure so we can build our SME
Supply Chains It's that sort of Positive
Growth they want to see
um I just want to put a talk like I
guess uh just go out a little bit and
just talk a little bit about the state
of the economy and put it into some
context we talked about some of the
challenges whether it's trade whether
it's inflation do you think it's harder
for businesses now than it has been in
previous years you know even during
covid or during the financial crash or
things a bit more optimistic
if you'd ask me a year ago
what energy bills were really spiraling
and we had businesses with 200 3400
increases they were saying to me this is
worse than covid
but the energy package has really helped
them with a little bit of forward view
we are now seeing inflation hopefully
peaking forecast to be five percent by
the end of the year look it's going to
be a hard year it's going to be a tricky
year
but supporting businesses Now isn't
about subsidies or handouts it's about
investing in those businesses so they're
sort of fit for the future to make the
most is make the most of it as we come
out of the difficult times it does feel
like inflation is such a huge thing
whether it's from a business perspective
you know you talk about the energy bills
um and at the worst being worse than uh
the pandemic but also of course for
families particularly thinking about
food bills and stuff like that a recent
analysis in the financial times
suggested that on present Trends the
average polish family will be richer
than a British family by 2030 a
Slovenian family in just 2024. I mean is
the UK now you know a poor country with
just a wealthy pocket in London and the
southeast do we need to re-look at you
know the kind of economy we are
we need to use the chamber Network
around the country the structure we have
in place to support local business and
remember local businesses are people
they they employ local people they
support their communities you know we
saw that we had the leveling up
secretary earlier I said to Michael
Michael a chamber network has been
leveling up for 250 years so support
local businesses inject money into the
system let's use those solvency too
changes that the chance has been talking
about to help support and grow local
business because that helps local people
really interesting thank you very much
for being on the program thank you